hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the 2019 Isle of Man
chess tournament it's Grandmaster Ahmed
oddly vs. chest comes second favors
commentator Robert has now it is an
interesting game and we're gonna dive
straight into it but before that I would
just like to mention a few things about
my previous video the game between the
hunk art and soul Aikido the reason it
you know it came to this
misunderstanding is that okay I received
the pigeon from my friend and then I
published it on Twitter and I went to
sleep when I woke up in the morning I
went to the chess 24 website where I
always check the moves and then I
confirmed them on the chest balm website
where I just copy paste them into my
analysis software when I do the analysis
and the the moves were as they were the
queen of sex move happened before any
rook the g8 ideas and I presented it as
such and I was I was I mean I it it did
seem suspicious to me that it happened
but then again you know it's just things
always happen and the reason I decided
not to take it on the video is because I
have a personal policy never to take it
on my videos one of the first videos I
made on this channel is bobby fischer
beats a grandmaster in ten moves and
that video is still publicly available
you can check it out even though that
game lasted over 40 moves I ended the
video after the tenth move and I said
that a Fischer's opponent resigned the
game were in fact that is completely
incorrect and I received a lot of
negative comments about that but it it
serves as a reminder to not to make
videos about chess games you know did I
think I know by heart so as of that
video I never again made a video made a
video bottle game that I remember by
heart so I always check the PG and
before making the video and here i
blundered into such a situation that all
the websites in the world had the pigeon
wrong even now at the moment I'm making
this video all the websites still have
the pigeon wronged a show that Queen
turfs f6 move was played and first I
thought yeah I'm not gonna show the move
but then my friend said yeah I mean you
could show it it might be you know it
might be fun for subscribers
you know maybe they will feel less bad
about the games
play you know mimic fun in you know
entertaining video about it and I said
okay I will do it and then as soon as I
published it well not as soon but some
maybe half an hour I started receiving
messages that just base India already
has this video with analysis on their
Channel and that route captures energy
it happened first and then the game
fouled as it did whereas they hunker
want a really nice game against a much
higher rated opponent now another reason
I decided not to take it down this video
is because well it will it shows you the
game and it also drives traffic to the
chess base India's channel where you
will see this game and I I don't know I
wouldn't see this game if it wasn't for
for the supposed mistake and this way a
lot of you will see the original game
and the original game is well it is a
very nice game so that's just something
I wanted to mention before checking it
out and I changed the the title of the
video I changed the description of the
video so everyone knows what's happening
some we were saying that I should also
take down the video because it you know
shows that women don't really play good
chess I don't agree I think that there
are ugly comments about the winners
chess on this video and pretty much on
every video on the Internet where women
play but that says nothing about woman's
chest that only says something about the
people that write comments like that so
yeah I I mean the video I'm keeping the
video on as a further reminder to always
triple check everything and well it's
just I don't have a I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna take the video down that's
just what I wanted to mention before
checking it out and although I did
mention it in the previous video in the
comment section in my pin comment I will
also invite everyone out to check out
chess base India's version of the video
where you have an interview between
chakra and younger they hunker so you
can also check out her analysis of the
game and see that it was in fact a
brilliant game that you played so just
wanted to mention that and I'm pretty
sure I wanted to mention a couple of
other stuff but
that's I think that's that that's that
was suffice it before we check out this
game so that being said Ahmed Ali versus
Robert S or oddly with the white pieces
opens with knife to f3 so we have we
have the directly opening Knight to f6
by Robert we have c4 and now G 6 will be
three procuring to fianchetto the dark
square Bishop and sorry that's a king
Bishop to g7 we have Bishop to b2 and
now castles g3 oddly prepares the finger
to both sides of the board we have c6
preparing d5 and Bishop the g2 so the 5
this is all very standard and white
castles here and now a5
we have d3 by white and now there are
some very popular moves here like nice
to a six also a4 is an idea here but the
move black plays b5 is not a new moving
the position but it's an extremely rare
move in the position so it or something
has placed very often he knows about it
or or something he prepared specifically
for this game but now here with my
ability with a non move Queen to c2 is a
non move but here we have C capture son
b5 and it is already as of mu9 that we
have a completely new game
so Casey characters and b5 with Knight
to c3 now attacking the b5 pawn and the
Queen to b6 guarding the b5 pawn rook
the c1 developing the rook and now comes
Knight to c6 and here we have a for
attacking b5 there's a double attack on
the b5 now and although you could put be
forged get this night over to b5 has
decides to go for Bishop to a6 instead
and okay a character son b5 will show
characters on b5 offering the bishop
pair for the moment but why it says I
can always capture that there's no rush
if you want to bring the bishop back you
will have to waste another move
so Bishop to e3 getting the bishop on
this very nice diagonal also attacking
the e7 point if if the knight moves and
rook F the c8 now the C file is the only
open file on the board so you should put
your rooks on that file we have Knights
the a4 by white
now offering a trade here and queen back
to d8 saying I don't want to trade you
can leave your knight on the rim and
here we have Bishop to h3 a very rare
opportunity to see two bishops on a3 and
h3 not something you will see very often
so the roof on c8 is under attack we
have E 6 by Hess with Knight
the c5 now and excellent outpost for the
night and now comes Queen to e7 it seems
odd putting the Queen in front of the
bishop like this but the knight cannot
move as the bishop is unprotected here
so it's basically the stronger piece
controlling the the knight and the
weaker piece we have Queen to d2 by
white connecting rooks developing the
Queen and now comes Knight the b4 just
the blocking bishops defense of the
night here of course you can capture
nothing wrong with that but there is a
double attack on your c5 Knight here so
here white plays Queen to e3 and this is
only move 19 but already we have
something very interesting happening on
the board feel free to pause the video
here and try to find well the best move
for black in this position well I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on winning a piece and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
actually D for D for just blocking the
Queen's defense often I hear point being
you cannot capture with the Queen to
keep on defending the knight and c5 if
you capture with the Queen Knight d7 you
open up an attack against the Queen and
there's also now a triple attack against
the knight and c5 so you don't have a
move here you have to move the Queen and
then just nice captures and see if I win
the peace so after d4 white had to go
for Knight captures on d4 and then we
have rook captures on c5 just grabbing
that piece rook captures with Queen
captures and de now rook the c1 ok
pushing the Queen back Queen to b6 and
the now comes the Knight captures on b5
you cannot cap you cannot trade Queens
here as you have to recapture the night
so Queen captures on b5 and now comes
Luke the c5 just attacking the black
Queen Queen to a6 and now comes Queen to
c1
so the queen is now doubling up a double
up with the rook and the C file and
white puts a lot of pressure on blacks
position but black is still up a piece
which is not something to take lightly
we have Knight F to d5 by hesse and now
comes a bishop back to g2 pushing
putting the bishop on this nice diagonal
not allowing the Nike to move but Hess
finds a nice way to unpin he plays
Knight to c3 and it's just just a very
interesting idea of course if you
capture the rook
for example Bishop captures then you get
a nightcap for Sonny - and you lose the
Queen so not something you want to do
and also what else can you do you could
play rook captures and c3 sort of trying
to win two pieces for the rook but then
black has nice - a - attacking the rook
and the Queen and now you're just gonna
recapture here so also not possible so
here
oddly goes for Bishop to f3 he keeps an
eye on the e2 pawn and now rook the c8
so everything working nicely for black
we have Queen to g5 at defending the c5
rook and now comes h6 pushing the Queen
back so if you don't want to mess
something up and not keep an eye on the
rook as there aren't any squares you can
use here to keep an eye on the rook rook
captures an c8 we have Queen captures
and see it and now Queen captures an a5
and okay
white did grab a couple of points it's
six points white four points black so
for the for the piece you have two
points and if you can somehow get your
past beep on rolling up the board it
will be it will be could be very nice
you do have a light square but regarding
b7 if you can get your dark square
Bishop somewhere like f4 maybe to guard
the queening square it could be possible
but we have a nice to see - now offering
well not offering but attacking the a3
pony want to further trade down with
Bishop to c5 not allowing this trade and
now comes Knight the e1 or preparing to
capture on f3
we've butcher back to h1 white cannot
allow any trades as sees down a piece
and now Knight captures an e2 with check
King f1 now both Knights are under
attack and now comes the night
characters on d3 inviting the King
the character here but doesn't really
matter if in captures just night factors
on c5 and yes you can start pushing your
beep on but after the night moves it's
not really you will not be able to do
anything with this passport as a black
still has a knight a bishop and the
queen
so with Bishop to e3 of course not
allowing this trade and now Queen to c2
preparing Queen 2d 1 followed by well
whatever who who widely decides to play
with Bush of the e4 now pinning this
night and now Queen to d1 with check
we've came to g2 and now comes Knights
the e1 again with check King back to f1
and now although you have a lot of very
interesting discoveries feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
D best discovery in the position while I
give you a couple of seconds for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding the best
discovery in the position 93 does win
Knight the d3 does win but tonight the
c2 is the quickest way to the victory
and in fact it was in this position on
move 37 that I'm entirely resigned the
game and an excellent victory with the
black pieces for for Robert s he he
resigned here because well after you
move the king there really is no other
option you cannot block as e1 Square is
covered after he moved the King you're
getting Knight captures on e3 with check
F captures and now just Queen Queen to
g1 check kink the h3 and now everything
is working properly
Queen to f1 check and now but after
Bishop to G to Knight the g1 check King
to g4 and now just f5 check you don't
really have a move here King to h4 and
now Bishop to f6 will be checkmate so
this is a pretty straight forward the
mating sequence so of course oddly did
not need to consider didn't need to
continue the game after Knights the C to
check he simply resign the game because
even if he doesn't yet made it chances
are very slim that he will be able to do
anything here and it's a pretty force
variation so of course he calculated it
and very very quickly so very
interesting game and the very well with
very strange moments that such strong
player as Ahmed oddly
we'll blunder a piece like that but it
does happen if the PGN to this game is
correct because now I will have to
wonder about every game if the pigeon is
correct before posting it and I was also
contacted by a subscriber Eric he said
he sent me this quote by Rachel volscian
it's not how we make mistakes but how we
correct them that defines us stating
that I definitely should take down the
video that I made but I prefer to
correct my mistakes but by not
pretending that I made them so I own up
to my mistakes and whatever I did in
that video this is an entertainment
channel after all and it doesn't it
doesn't portray either of the players in
a bad spot light if anything it's an 11
minute video of me making an idiot of
myself so that yeah just wanted to share
that with you guys so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it we're gonna cover
at least one more game from this round
tomorrow so then we're gonna check out
the standings a little bit more and some
other interesting games so of course
feel free to use the hashtag suggestion
I would like to thank John Newland Chris
Nichol Felton Torben Anderson Wade
Coleman and Anton's Oracle for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think'll for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the coverage of the isle
of man chess tournament checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and well as
usual everything goes that happens in
the chess world hopefully the pigeons
will be correct this time so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day